look what's happening look what's
happening I'm so proud of you Pete home
thank you dr. H oh oh thank you John you
have your own show sort of well yeah I
mean it's yeah we making it yeah we're
making it nurse you're being seen by
people mine are being seen by pain and I
hope that ours is too but you you win
it's always been a contest between us
Peter and you when I've known you for a
long time that's true I met you you wore
billowing khakis over grey new Balance
you were a Boston Red Sox cap in the
same fleece everyday I dress and now
look at you I kind of dressed like I was
divorced before I was divorced
by krumping around the frozen food aisle
yeah whoo your ex-wife just looked at
you and when I might as well complete
the picture I didn't need to go that
early to that no but I of course did
plan on going well you roasted me before
I've roasted you uh I don't know if you
know this but Pete Holmes is a big fan
of Pete Holmes and so uh he organized
his own roast in what 2007 around that
around that time so way before he
deserved it at all like now it would
make some sense right this was just like
hey we're all standing around it one day
he's like I'm holding a roast of myself
all right
it was my 30th birthday it was your 30th
birthday yeah I didn't know that I'm
pretty you wouldn't have hit the ex-wife
stuff though because I think we're
similar we don't know how to make fun of
people
is that true do you think that about
yourself I go too hard I can't you know
yeah no I know what you mean yeah two
modes yeah he's like something I can't
give you a light dusting like I'll give
your shirt you know yeah I just have to
be like your wife left you
no it's fantastic it's Fanta we did a
show he's way better off by the way you
have said a lot of nightmare kind things
I'm sorry to make a sincere you've also
come therefore basement wonderful you
did a show with me recently I was gonna
say you open but really we did a show
together no I was an opener and it was
fun I was a special guest you were the
special guest and and you do you
remember how you brought me up the once
and future king of late night I would
never have teeth that up true I was
wondering I was like oh he just wants me
to say that again no yes I said you've
stuck a real I said you've stuck around
for Pete which is more than I can say
for his ex-wife ladies and gentlemen the
once nope the once and future king of
late-night Pete oh that's right yeah I
softened it by giving you Johnny
Carson's title
do you remember Kumail had a roast joke
that night uh yeah I remember he had a
few good ones he had one do you couple
really great I had some great one he
went hey sorry I'm gonna do the voice
hey Peter your ex-wife called just
kidding she's too busy with the new baby
you never forget that you never forget
that even I don't mention the baby
good to see we totally missed him so
sorry